[Música]
todos queremos que latinoamérica es una
región llena de países desarrollados y
si alguien no lo cree de la misma forma
aún así le conviene pero tenemos un
problema
sabían que de todos los investigadores
científicos del mundo solamente el 4 por
ciento es de latinoamérica y que de este
4% solamente un tercio son mujeres pero
que tiene que ver la cantidad de
científicos con el potencial de
crecimiento de los países
latinoamericanos
soy amable tengo 14 años y quiero ser
astrofísico aunque también me encanta la
historia y las artes marciales pero hoy
voy a empezar hablándoles de historia
así un paréntesis
como ustedes sabrán en la mayoría de las
charlas ted se usan slides en power
point pero como yo soy kinestésico y
luego no sé qué hacer con estas manos
locas que aquí ven voy a usar algunos
slides flights en 3d
así que volviendo a la historia a lo
largo de la historia hemos visto como
las potencias mundiales han bastado su
desarrollo y poderío en avances
científicos desde los mayas que
gracias a sus increíbles conocimientos
en astronomía lograron colocar sus
pirámides de tal forma que en algunos
momentos del año se podían ver
verdaderos espectáculos solamente usando
la luz del sol
pasando por los ingleses que con la
ayuda de la máquina vapor
se convirtieron en los pioneros de la
revolución industrial hasta los
estadounidenses que gracias a inventos
como la bombilla o
el mismísimo carro
empezaron su gran boom económico después
de la guerra civil
incluso sin hablar de potencias
esta charla no sería posible sin la
ayuda de la ciencia que usamos
cotidianamente casi sin darnos cuenta
ahorita mismo estoy usando un micrófono
que envía una señal con ondas de radio a
una consola que con ayuda de bocinas
logra amplificar el sonido de mi voz
para que todos en la sala me puedan oír
mientras tanto estoy siendo grabado en
audio y vídeo para que esta charla sea
posteriormente subida a internet para
que más gente pueda disfrutar de ella a
través de wifi que fue una invención de
un radio astrónomo
imagínense es este radio astrónomo
hubiera sido mexicano
que hubiera pasado
por eso necesitamos más ciencia pero
como lo hacemos pues al estilo de jack
el destripador
por partes
hay que empezar por el principio que
vendría siendo la escuela y los jóvenes
les voy a contar que siempre ha tenido
una duda existencial
si las matemáticas son juegos de lógica
si la física es la comprensión de los
movimientos del universo si la biología
es el misterio de la vida
si la química son los ingredientes
básicos del universo
si la historia son aventuras épicas amor
drama acción y hasta comedia
mientras que la geografía son lugares
exóticos y desconocidos y la lengua es
absolutamente todo lo que te puedas
imaginar por qué demonios es tan
aburrido ir a la escuela
en serio porque un ser que es tan
curioso como el humano se aburre tanto
en la escuela
les voy a contar de un hecho traumático
que tuve cuando estaba en nada más y
nada menos que en preescolar
cuando estaba en preescolar a mí me
encantaban los dinosaurios eran mi cosa
favorita en el mundo y quería ser
paleontólogo al darse cuenta de esto mis
padres no tardaron en llenar mi cuarto
de cosas de dinosaurios libros de
dinosaurios juguetes de dinosaurios
documentales de dinosaurios
'jurassic park' no es un documental de
dinosaurios
un día le propuso a mis amiguitos que
jugáramos a los dinosaurios como no nos
dejaban llevar juguetes a la escuela
nosotros teníamos que ser los
dinosaurios entonces hacíamos las mímica
si los sonidos del rock de los
dinosaurios
estas lagartijas gigante parte de pájara
las que nos encantaba interpretar
vivieron durante un período conocido
como el mesozoico que se divide en tres
etapas que vendrían siendo el triásico
el jurásico y el cretácico entonces
cuando vi que un amigo mío estaba
jugando a hacer el braquiosaurio del
periodo jurásico mientras que el otro
era el tyrannosaurus rex del periodo
cretácico cuando estos dos jamás se
conocieron como qué te pasa no me faltes
al respeto de esta manera pensé que
éramos amigos
obviamente no quisieran volver a jugar a
los dinosaurios conmigo
por otros comentarios del estilo me
convertí en el rarito del salón
y en cuanto a mis estudios me sentía de
la misma manera como el raro
no tardaron en diagnosticar me quedé a
hiperactividad ya saben el clásico
afortunadamente mis padres aquí
presentes
no me medicaron y soy normal
mis intereses por la ciencia siguieron
creciendo y mis problemas con el sistema
también esto entre otras cosas llevaron
a mi familia ya mi empezar a hacer home
school o educación en casa pero entiendo
que otros raritos como yo está en una
situación en la que estudiar en casa no
les sea posible qué hay de ellos todos
hemos tenido algo que nos interesa o que
nos apasiona y no tiene que ser
necesariamente la ciencia puede ser la
música la pintura la medicina el deporte
los masajes de pies
también puede ser son pasiones a las que
se les tiene que dar seguimiento pero
entonces nos damos cuenta de que muchas
de las cosas que nos enseñan en la
escuela realmente no significan nada
para nosotros solamente tenemos que
memorizar una lista de conocimientos
ponerlas en un examen y luego
las olvidamos
y si no me creen a ver cuántas personas
en esta sala recuerdan el contenido de
su último examen de biología
y si alguien de hecho si se acuerda no
es biólogo
amigo que me decirte que tienes un
problema
y seguramente alguno de ustedes ha
estado en clase y alguno de sus
compañeros se le ocurre decir profesor
profesor esto va a venir en el examen
se supone que en la escuela tú vienes a
aprender el mundo gira alrededor de un
examen pero ojo se supone se supone
por esto digo que el sistema educativo
se debe centrar en que uno aprenda se
apasione y se exprese y se aprenda de
verdad no que se memorice para un examen
tenemos que aprender algo que no sea
significativo que no sea interesante que
se aproveche nuestra curiosidad natural
que hay mejor en este mundo que un niño
pregunto
hay que ayudar a los jóvenes y niños a
que descubramos nuestras pasiones e
intereses y apoyarnos en vez de vernos
como niños raros
y por favor que nos escuchen
las clases deben dejar de ser monólogos
y convertirse en conversación es una de
las cosas que más necesitamos en la
actualidad es una juventud analítica los
alumnos deben presentarles sus dudas a
sus maestros o incluso cuestionar los
hay que fomentar el pensamiento crítico
y aunque el alumno que cuestiona no
tenga la razón hay que celebrar que se
atreve a cuestionar los jóvenes debemos
ser escuchados y no sólo por el sistema
educativo los padres de familia también
deben estar al tanto de los intereses y
pasiones de sus hijos y estar dispuestos
a ayudarlos estás acciones llevarán a
que más chicos sigan el camino de la
ciencia
o de cualquier otra materia pero con
verdadera pasión
pero qué tal si el problema no está
realmente en la educación qué tal es en
realidad está en los propios jóvenes
pues la juventud de hoy ama el lujo es
maleducada desprecia la autoridad no
respeta a sus mayores y chismes mientras
debería trabajar
el problema es que esto lo dijo sócrates
en el año 400 antes de cristo
y no me malentiendan
yo me imagino que la juventud griega que
le tocó ver a sócrates era simplemente
devastadora
se la pasaban en el teatro eran fans de
los espartanos hacían grafitis en el
templo de zeus
de lo peor
obviamente estas ideas ya son muy
antiguas y ya va siendo hora de
cambiarlas desgraciadamente estas
opiniones siguen estando activas en la
actualidad como los motes que te ponen
dependiendo del año en el que naciste
como los famosísimos millennials la
generación x la generación zeta
los baby boomers los griegos malcriados
ya es hora de dejar de etiquetar y hay
que empezar a vernos a los jóvenes como
lo que realmente somos generadores de
conocimiento y las personas que vamos a
guiar el futuro las nuevas generaciones
de jóvenes científicos también necesitan
seguimiento si queremos más ciencia y
latinoamérica necesitamos darles más
apoyo a los científicos en latinoamérica
desgraciadamente la inversión en ciencia
y latinoamérica es muy escasa todos los
países latinoamericanos a excepción de
brasil invierten menos del 1 por ciento
de su producto interno bruto en ciencia
y tecnología mientras tanto los países
que podríamos denominar desarrollados
como eeuu china corea del sur
los países de la unión europea invierten
más del 2 por ciento de su producto
interno bruto en ciencia y tecnología
esta situación lleva a que los jóvenes
científicos latinoamericanos que salen
de las universidades también salgan de
latinoamérica a eso se le llama fuga de
cerebros y es un gran obstáculo si lo
que queremos es tener más científicos en
latinoamérica les voy a decir que las
mentes brillantes sorprendentemente no
son estúpidas y saben muy bien dónde les
conviene quedarse
por esto es que hay que darle más
oportunidades a los científicos en
latinoamérica para que en el futuro que
se generen nuevas patentes que
impulsarán a la economía y a la
industria de la región hay que darle la
oportunidad de los niños de hacer
ciencia ya está experimentando o viendo
su utilidad porque la ciencia se vive a
diario incluso jugando
esto llevará a que se generen más
científicos sin distinción de género
señores
que en el futuro nos brindarán grandes
avances que harán que tanto
latinoamérica como el mundo prosperen
porque la ciencia no es solamente de los
científicos nos pertenece a todos
[Aplausos]